hi I'm Erik Bosse the vengers endgame is
being re-released in theaters with
marvel head Kevin Feige making a little
cameo at a press event for spider-man
far from home and now seeing the
re-release with new footage including it
sounds like a new post-credit scene yeah
for those of you who wanted more from
the credits after in-game fix it [ __ ]
is on it and this channel isn't the only
one milk in and getting dry I'm gonna
break down the new footage and all the
details you need to know about it
customary spoiler warning in case any
speculation is it being too accurate to
your life experience and I guess you
insist on being blindsided in every
moment okay here is what we know first
this re-release will not be an extended
cut of the movie this won't be like Zack
Snyder's Ultimate editions a Batman V
Superman or that Snyder cut of Justice
League nor will it be an alternate recut
of in game with deleted scenes mixed in
like once upon a Deadpool or the
Deadpool to blu-ray super duper cut
however Feige has said that this end
game rerelease will feature a post
credit sequence of some sort including
extra scenes that were not included in
the theatrical release some kind of
tribute and in his vaguely defined words
surprises so what could these be well we
have heard about a number of scenes that
the Russo brothers shot for Avengers
endgame but ultimately deleted from the
film these include an alternate Indian
scene with Tony Stark in an older Morgan
Stark played by Catherine Lankford and
which the father and daughter greet each
other in that orange colored soul realm
and Morgan lets her father go lets him
move on this bonus footage could be
composed of that kind of deleted
material or we could be seeing a new
special post-credit stinger that gives
us a hint at what's coming next in the
MCU like something for the Black Widow
movie currently in production you know
something to clarify detach the Romanovs
death in this movie since unlike Tony
Stark she got no funeral yet she's
supposed to be in her own movie I guess
probably a prequel something just tell
us something about that please we could
also get a tease for Doctor Strange -
still a development or the Eternals
movie or updates about the Marvel Disney
Plus series is Loki Falcon and Winter
Soldier
one division Marvel what if reven the
Hawkeye series that was rumored
in the works that jeremy renner might
have been alluding to in an interview
this week so there could be some
indication of how recently acquired Fox
Marvel properties like Deadpool the
Fantastic Four or the x-men could one
day tie into the MCU or maybe just a
quick little scene indicating the next
big villain on the horizon with Feige
now having access to names like Doctor
Doom and Galactus actually earlier this
year 5ds seemed pretty giddy about a
Galactus cameo showing up in the movie
Vice cameo which at the time I pointed
out as a little odd because for Feige to
be part of the negotiations for a
character that was still during the time
of that movie's production the property
of another studio implies that Feige
might have been brewing his own secret
plans of the character in his own movie
universe and when it comes to a post
credit teaser we're not talking major
production folks like sure there's a
good chance Feige is just re releasing
an in-game to try to make a few more
millions of dollars to top avatar as a
highest-grossing film of all time rather
than this always being part of his plan
and he always intended to have some
extra bonus material for a second
release but but consider that in the two
months of endgames release there has
been plenty of time for Marvel Studios
to whip up some extra stuff for us like
the post-credits scene after the first
Avengers the schwarmann scene was shot
days before that movie's wide release
after the movie's red-carpet premiere
and the first Avengers other
post-credits scene revealed an all CGI
Thanos that required no actor to be cast
in the role or to record any lines and
post-credit scenes of other superhero
franchises like the amazing spider-man 2
and x-men apocalypse hinted at future
villains with mere props and VFX
graphics like we were able to pull so
much from simply the graphics on Nick
Fury's freakin pager in the post-credits
scene for Infinity Ward now sure it was
cool to see the rest of the world dust
into chaos and for fury to get him one
final mother floor Ken but the thing
that got all of us the most pumped was
just the simplest part of it now Feige
doing this probably means spider-man far
from home will not feature any major
post-credit teases for MC news future
which makes sense because that movie is
a joint production between Marvel
Studios and Sony but I would be
surprised if far from home doesn't leave
us with something like homecoming still
feature a post-credits scene with Adrian
Toomes in prison
beating Mac Gargan scorpion threatening
to put spider-man's severed head and
dryer ruin all of his white clothes so
we could get a post-credits scene after
far from home that sets up whatever's
next in these Marvel spider-man films
like a sinister six movie or a tie-in
with venom and going forward after this
in-game re-release and after far from
home in July it sounds like Kevin Feige
will finally announce what his film
release plans are for Marvel phase 4 it
was announced that Marvel will actually
return to comic-con Hall H this year
which is the third weekend of July so at
that point fixify geek will probably
mend all of our broken hearts comment
down below with what you think the new
endgame post-credits scene will be
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
boss and subscribed into rock stars for
breakdowns of everything Marvel thank
you for joining me and Oh Kevin Feige no
no no we're gonna make it fun of you
we're just breaking down the details of
the end games rerelease well I should
break you damn mother
oh my I guess we're in the street I'll
go see him four more times just make
more times